yes because before there was no way that
white can be be better right yeah but
right here we have a moment where
he has to calculate extremely well yeah
this is this is the problem actually dr
quinn the hc5
and suddenly great opportunities for
white pieces
yeah you definitely don't want to let
the white knight into c5 and if not then
just dropping a pawn
oh wow he's played e4 your first
intention
so okay let's see what is this
okay
so white has at least three candidate
moves
okay actually he's not going to play
this because of bishop g4 i think okay
and this is the problem
and then knight e5 so if yeah and also
black skin
one
then
first it takes everything and on h2 as
well
or
maybe bishop f2 is also something okay
okay so let's see because e4 is uh
extremely powerful at first this is what
we thought right yeah so what happened
we should have trusted those yeah
bishop
c1 right so bishop g5 is there
now black can go back queen d8
okay this is one option but what about
bishop f3 we didn't check bishop f3
is that possible
okay let's take it let's
no but this is uh
i think no chance of survival okay so
but this doesn't feel bad at all
football he's actually played knight
takes played 94. so we haven't found a
reputation of this one so far
the other lines looked quite promising
for black so knight takes d4 e takes d3
is that also knight takes f5 or is this
running into a refutation somehow
because rook takes f5 coin takes d3 and
white is just
happy after e takes d
three okay he's playing e takes f3
i was going to say after e63 knight
takes f5 there was also queen d8 but
what is this
okay what is happening here does he want
queen maybe ages bishop f8
but bishop h3
wow
okay so unexpected
all the pins in the position
[Laughter]
seven minutes on the clock bishop h3
yeah unpleasant surprises i mean it's so
easy to blunder right now it's so easy
to miss one of these checks one of these
queen sacrifices
wow
bishop h3 yeah what a move what nerves
to justify i got the piece
of e6 yeah find it and execute it rook
f2 f2 played by magnus and okay this
does step out of all of these deadly
um
what about you
okay does he just want to take with the
pawn well if he takes with the rook then
takes takes queen d4 and queen f2 right
and game over yeah so this cannot be the
move so what about he has to take f3
takes g takes f3 how do you bring
another piece into the attack
95 runs you know 95 d4 right i should
have five still though oh yeah but this
is this is not what he's looking for i
guess
karyakin do you reckon rook f2 was on
his radar
because that's a clever move okay it was
on his radar
gf3 well rook f3 i think was the only
move so probably knight e5 this is what
we were thinking right okay
pretty much
does it force d4 i mean d4 wants to be
played by white
well i think uh well definitely this is
the first move we have to check bishop
f5
rook f5 okay five
every move's a surprise right here rook
f5
and magnus has four minutes
magnus now about to okay he has to but
you have a rook g5 check what uh so this
is a blunder for example ah okay five of
the goals
yeah mates
so d4 d4 is played queen d4 and magnus
he's reaching for his rook he retreats
back to a3 with two minutes and 24
seconds left on his clock
okay so stopping the threat of rook
takes f3 for black and he wants to
regroup his rook i guess to d3 yeah also
bishop e3 may be supporting that bishop
e3 is also something maybe now as well
this f4 idea makes more sense on the
next turn just bringing that rook across
hitting the h3 bishop that's uh true
okay
magnus wow what a move rook a3
i don't think white has any dangers okay
he doesn't play he doesn't play
f7
f7 so that's an admission that this rook
f5 idea
wasn't quite correct well he wants to
bring his bishop back to f5 rook e3
played still
over two minutes for magnus he
stabilizes his position i think black
wants probably to go bishop f5 and of
course it's very difficult to
i'm not even sure why it is better
actually because the black bishop is so
powerful
but uh definitely uh magnus is not in
the real danger right now
anymore
while the queens remain carrick and has
attacking chances some tricks but
if max can i go rook a7 no he went
bishop f5 okay
he wants to make sure he goes bishop f5
and knight f4
i guess a7 would have just been met by
rookie one and control
queen d8 okay i like the screen d8
giving some ideas to give a check and
control the black squares
but he had to admit look everything is
controlled all the squares
all the squares
controlled by black so this was
something very
important and essential yeah literally
every square in the first
magnus is under 120
incredibly difficult situation to play
but of course he stabilized he played
rookie one so he covers the first rank
he covers the problems with queen g5 and
also most importantly he doesn't allow
the black knight to go to f4
okay rookie seven row d7 is the most
logical but he had to make sure that
he's
not blundering anything queen e3 and now
key seven is an option to go back and
forth
he had to repeat the position and there
is a good chance that this will be the
idea of course he wants to
go queen e8 right now yeah
or queen g5 or queen g5 as another
option as well what about who's d4
okay he's playing for the win then he
played he played d4 he doesn't want to
give up all his hopes but really this g6
knight is so essential there covering
the e7 square also
yeah
covering squares and also always ready
to jump right
to f4 now maybe h4 it's a defender for
the moment but any second it can jump to
f4 which is actually an
awfully strong threat right now yeah to
go to h3 does white have to try and get
these queens off
it's not the most practical well you
mean queen g5 right yeah and this is
what he played so he's going to be
captured on g5 i guess there is no other
move
it's going to be take stakes and
capturing c for the phone
and it feels like black is out of danger
yes material down still but
it's going to be extremely hard to break
through that and magnus has one minute
and 10 seconds right now in the game
what about rook c3 attacking the f3 pawn
yeah
that would be perfect they don't have to
ride the move anymore at least magnus
because he's under 5 minutes
i would regroup my bishop to d5 but
that's not possible for the moment b5 b5
yeah i was about to say it's maybe
slightly annoying for black that he
can't just completely liquidate the
queenside pawns or can't initiate any
exchanges there but well i don't know if
white is playing rook c1 no he goes king
f2
maybe rook c1 there would have been some
tactical issues yeah maybe some knight
e5 yes you have to keep your your pawn
on c6 right
so c5 okay so he does try to liquidate
yeah he goes for uh
simplify the position goes on d5 with
his rook possibly actually there is an
exchange of possibility for white i
think with rook c1 so let's see whether
he wants to exchange the rooks
or he wants to play rook a2 or something
to go to the seventh there we go he does
play rook c1 offering the rook trade
this feels like the best position he's
had all game i guess
but i'm not sure black is getting away
if they simplify the position yeah with
opposite color bishops yes because
simply after this black goes bishop d3
let's say rook d2 and once white gets to
d7
the g7 is falling off yeah i guess black
has to put the knight in e6 and try to
hold that okay he tries to keep the
rooks on
that's
very instructive from karak and when you
when you're playing with the pieces when
you're in exchange down keep your
remaining rook d2 now he has to be taken
care of whether is he going to be bishop
d3 to enter into the pin
or
or d3 it must be so frustrating for
karjakin to have to handle this position
and they get to an end game where
practically magnus will collect a lot a
lot of moves he will just able to make
moves getting 10 seconds
raise his time and then think about it
and really the g7 pawn if that falls off
that then it's completely over five
already just wins a pawn as well
he took on d2
bishop takes d2
knight e5 okay so magnus doesn't believe
in fortresses sergey needs to hope
somehow that he can set up
his knights and bishop
correctly if you give up the b5 pawn
yeah c7 will be the next move there is
no other move yeah
there we go c7 and g7 is
already under heavy fire how do you even
defend now
king g6 and
put the knight back on d7 on f7 but
the b5 pawn is going to drop at some
point
if he could have kept the rooks on as
black yeah that would help him a lot
g6
but i doubt that he has
well he went b4 okay so small track
trap here bishop takes b4 knight d3
check
let's see what's going on it's going to
be what magnus is falling yeah
yeah not the most difficult trap we've
ever seen
rook b7
okay so bishop
e6 rook e7
i guess black wants to play knight c4 or
knight d3 and after bishop b4 he wants
to take knight f3
even that looks magnus is 18 seconds
okay he does play rook e7 gaining a bit
of time on the clock also creating a
serious threat black has to play knight
c4 or knight d3 check most likely giving
a check
king e3
bishop c4
bishop c4 what are you running for yeah
look e4
b3
ah there are still traps
there are only traps there are only
traps
you know b3 and that b pawn was running
so king d4 much more sensible now b3 is
not an issue is the piece just dropping
maybe it is
not b2 there's bishop c1
the two black pieces can't defend each
other
wow what a game as soon as magnus got
down to five minutes he just
enacted kind of
genius mode and
yeah
he found this great and
there we go another resignation hot off
the heels of the other game karjakin
resigns and magnus takes the lead in the
tournament for the first time
well he had a very difficult day and he
was um
yeah he was on the brink very crazy game
yeah magnus there we see he's not happy
that's probably because of the way he
played the opening
and the early middle game